joe biden has solved the racial
achievement gap
this took a long time you know some
people blamed this system
some people blamed cultural differences
but joe
has finally identified the real problem
black people just can't get accountants
the data shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
that's it they're great entrepreneurs
they just they just don't have
accountants you know they're such good
entrepreneurs that they don't know how
to call up
h r block but they have good ideas you
know that's what's really important
in business is having no one has any
ideas it's
ideas at a buck 50 i'll get you a cup of
coffee if only it were that easy
some conservatives are making the
argument because of joe biden's
stupid comments that he is a racist
and i guess in a way he is but they're
making the argument not that he's
uh just a racist generally but that he's
a white supremacist
because he's made these comments about
black people he said that you know
barack obama's the first clean
articulate black man
in american politics or something to
that effect that was a bit offensive
he said that uh poor kids are just as
talented as white kids that was a bit
offensive
and now he said that black entrepreneurs
can't succeed because they don't know
how to call
h r block but but i i don't
i don't think he's a white supremacist i
think this argument of you know
democrats are the real white
supremacists i think that's
kind of silly i think it's a bit of a
coping mechanism
i don't think that republicans or
conservatives are racist i mean i
frankly i don't even know what that word
means anymore
it's been so watered down to me nothing
but i don't think conservatives or
republicans hold any particular
racial animosity at all i don't think
they think about race very much
whatsoever and i
say this with some authority being a
conservative republican myself
and it certainly is the case that
democrats and leftists do think about
race a lot
but they're not white supremacists i
just think that that's a
silly statement to make they are
advancing a racial caste system
but they want it to disadvantage whites
and they wanted to give they want to
give advan
just like affirmative action give
advantages to certain groups like black
people and hispanics
and disadvantage other groups like white
people and asians that is what they're
calling for and and
any any way to twist that i think is
just a way to buy into the premise that
the only evil in the entire world is
anti-black racism
that's very bad there are other bad
things too
joe biden was pretty clear about this
the other day he came out
and he said that the single greatest
threat today in america is
is what would you say it's kovid maybe
no would you say that it's
the the lockdowns you know would you say
it's depression now would you say it's
drugs no would you say it's
violence in the streets from people like
blm and antifa no you know what it is
white supremacy according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal
threat to the homeland today not isis
not al-qaeda white supremacists
so that's just preposterous right i mean
i guess the single greatest threat is
heart disease
followed by what followed by various
other ailments and then if we're talking
about violence in the streets it's not
it's not from white supremacists okay
they're just there isn't a whole lot of
that
this statement doesn't even hold up if
you only look at race crimes
or rather if you only look at hate
crimes which have a racial component
very often when you look at hate crime
statistics and you look at
white perpetrators and black
perpetrators you find out that black
people are far more likely to commit
hate crimes than white people are i'm
sure there are many reasons for this and
one could discuss all of it i'm not
making any claim about what the reasons
are but i'm just saying if you believe
that white supremacy is the greatest
threat
that isn't even true when you're looking
at hate crimes
hate crimes a kind of silly category
because i guess it's the opposite of a
love crime
aren't too many love crimes as far as i
can tell we are now living in a system
that is upholding and advancing a new
sort of racial caste breaking out of the
colorblind society that everyone had
been
striving to create for a long time
there's now a racial caste system and
white people
are considered to be the sort of
embodiment of evil in this system the
single greatest threat
to the country ring my bell
l l ring my bell
my bill ring my belt just ring it click
it right now right now do it you
subscribe you'll get the notifications
and head on over
to apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher myspace
xanga aol instant messenger wherever we
have our audio podcast please subscribe
leave a five star review we really
appreciate it we'll see you next time
you